.
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT.
IF YOU'RE A NORMAL PERSON, IT'S
A PRETTY WEIRD EXPERIENCE
WATCHING JOE BIDEN'S PRESIDENCY
GET EUTHANIZED BY HIS OWN PARTY.
ON ONE HAND THERE'S AN
UNDENIABLE THRILL TO IT, YOU
HAVE TO ADMIT THAT.
BIDEN IS THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE
PRESIDENT IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
MORE THINGS HAVE BROKEN UNDER
HIS WATCH THAN UNDER ANY OTHER
PRESIDENT.
JOE BIDEN DESERVES TO BE DRIVEN
FROM OFFICE AND DISGRACED.
BREAKING FEDERAL CLASSIFICATION
RULES AND THE STUPIDDIST RULES
TAFANELY PASS AND IT'S MISSING
THE POINT.
BUT IT LOOKS LIKE THAT'S WHAT'S
GOING TO HAPPEN.
EVERYONE DAY WHEN A BIDEN LAWYER
SHOWS UP WITH MORE CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS LIKE A DOG WITH
ANOTHER DEAD CHIPMUNK UNDER THE
HOUSE AND THIS BUNCH UNDER THE
OFFICE AT PENN AND PAID FOR BY
THE CONNIE PARTY AT -- COMMUNIST
CHINA AT PENN AND FOUND IN THE
GARAGE NEAR THE SPORTS CAR IN
THE GARAGE AT DELAWARE AND WAIT
FOR ANOTHER DOCUMENT TROVE
ANNOUNCED AFTER THE ROUTINE
COLON OSCHEOPILOT.
PER NATHANIAL HACKETTE
WASHINGTON DOESN'T WANT --
PERMANENT WASHINGTON DOESN'T
WANT JOE BIDEN TO RUN FOR
PRESIDENT AGAIN AND THIS IS HOW
THEY'RE SENDING THE MESSAGE.
WHAT A MISSED OPPORTUNITY THIS
IS.
IF YOU'RE LOOKING FOR CRIMES JOE
BIDEN COMMITTED, THERE'S A LONG+
OUR COUNTRY IS BEING INVADED AND
THE WORLD IS ON THE BRINK OF
AMERICAN WAR AND AMERICAN CITIES
HAVE BECOME SLUMS AND OUR
ECONOMY IS IN SHAMBLES AND OUR
AIRPLANES NO LONGER TAKE OFF ON
TIME.
IT'S A DISASTER AND JOE BIDEN
AND HIS STAFF HAVE A HAND IN ALL
OF IT.
NO ONE DID ANYTHING TO STOP THE
ILLEGAL ALIENS AND NOW THEY'RE
ARRIVING AT THE RATE OF A
QUARTER MILLION A MONTH, WATCH.
>> CUSTOMS AND BORDER PROTECTION
SOURCES EXCLUSIVELY TELL FOX
NEWS MORE THAN 250,000 MIGRANTS
WERE ENCOUNTERED AT THE BORDER
IN THE MONTH OF DECEMBER.
ABOUT AS MANY PEOPLE LIVING IN
SCOTTSDALE, ARIZONA.
MAKING IT THE HIGHEST MONTH EVER
ON RECORD.
IN EAGLE PASS, TEXAS, THE
MIGRANT SEARCH CONTINUES.
LOCAL KENNY COUNTY RANCHER HAD A
HARROWING EXPERIENCE WITH
MIGRANTS ON HER PROPERTY.
>> I LOOKED OUT THE BACK AND
COULD VELI ILLEGALS WALKING UP
TO THE HOUSE.
I HAD GOTTEN A GUN, WHICH IS AN
AR-15.
I ASKED THEM TO STOP, GO AWAY,
AND HAD THE GUN IN MY HANDS AND
THEY, YOU KNOW, JUST KIND OF
LOOKED AT ME AND SMILED AND I
WAS LIKE GO AWAY.
THEY REFUSED TO DO SO.
>> THEY'RE ON THE OTHER SIDE OF
THE GLASS TRY --
>> TRYING TO GET IN AND NOT
BACKING DOWN.
>> NOT BACKING DOWN EVEN THOUGH
I HAVE A HIGH POWERFUL RIFLE IN
MY ARMS, THEY ARE NOT BACKING
DOWN.
THAT WAS SCARY.
>> >> Tucker: A RIFLE JOE
BIDEN WOULD LIKE TO TAKE AWAY
FROM HER.
>> IT'S THE ONE THING THAT
CANNOT BE UNDONE.
OUR GREAT GRANDCHILDREN WILL
LIVE WITH THE CONSEQUENCES OF
THIS.
YOU'D NEVER KNOW FROM THE NEWS
AND THERE'S AN EFFECTIVE MEDIA
BLACKOUT FROM THE POLICIES AND
DOWNSTREAM EFFECTS ON AMERICA.
THERE'S TOO MANY STRANGERS
POURING IN AT ONCE AND AS A
RESULT THE COUNTRY'S BECOMING
CHAOTIC.
HERE'S A RARE TELEVISION NEWS
PIECE ON WHAT HAPPENED WHEN
OFFICIALS IN NEW YORK DECIDED TO
HOUSE SOME OF JOE BIDEN'S
ILLEGAL ALIENS IN A HOTEL.
>> AN EMPLOYEE THERE SAYS
MIGRANTS MADE AN ABSOLUTE MESS
OF THE PLACE.
YOU'RE STANDING IN FRONT OF IT,
IS THAT TRUE?
>> YEAH, WHAT WE'RE HEARING FROM
THAT EMPLOYEE IS THAT THE HOTEL
IS COMPLETELY OVERRUN AND HE
SAYS OF COURSE SOME PEOPLE JUST
LOOKING FOR THAT BETTER LIFE BUT
AS A RESULT THE HOTEL IS A MESS
AND HE FEARS FOR HIS SAFETY.
>> IT'S ALL MIGRANTS.
WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN
DRUNK, USING MARIJUANA, THEY ARE
PUNCHING AND BEATING THEIR WIVES
OR GIRLFRIENDS.
WE HAVE TEENAGERS RUNNING
AROUND, WILD AROUND THE HOTEL
AND OPENING THE FIRE EXIT DOORS
AND DOING WHAT TEENAGERS DO IN
THE STAIRWAYS AND IT'S A MESS.
>> Tucker: IT'S A MESS HE
SAID.
OF COURSE IT IS.
THE WHOLE COUNTRY IS A MESS
BECAUSE JOE BIDEN HAS IGNORED
IMMIGRATION LAWS PASSED BY THE
CONGRESS.
THAT IS A CRIME AND IT HAS
KILLED HUGE NUMBERS OF
AMERICANS.
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS DEAD FROM
NARCOTICS.
>> FENTANYL IS CHANGING THE GAME
HERE IN SAN FRANCISCO AND CAN'T
BUY HEROIN OUT HERE ANYMORE AND
NOBODY BUYS RYAN HIGGINS SELLS
HEROIN AND -- OR SELLS HEROIN
AND FENTANYL IS THE MOST
DANGEROUS DRUG TO HIT THE
STREETS IN UNITED STATES IN
HISTORY.
>> FENTANYL KILLED MORE THAN
70,000 AMERICANS IN 12 MONTHS.
HERE IN SAN FRANCISCO, IT'S THE
DOMINANCE DRUG AND RESPONSIBLE
FOR THREE QUARTERS OF DRUG
OVERDOSES.
BRAZEN DRUG DEALING AND RAMPANT
DRUG USE IN THE SHADOW OF CITY
HALL, THE SAME CITY HILARES
TENT-LIKE STRUCTURES SAY
ACTIVELY EN-- HALL ACTIVELY
ENABLE THE FENTANYL CRISIS.
>> Tucker: EVERY GRAM CAME
OVER THE OPEN BORDER.
THE CHAOS AND CRIME IN THE CITY
AND INVASION UNDERWAY THROUGH
TEXAS, ARIZONA AND CALIFORNIA.
ALL OF THOSE DEEPLY CONCERNED
AMERICANS.
WE'RE NOT GUESSING AT THAT AND
POLLS SHOWED IT VERY CLEARLY.
BY CONTRAST, HOW MANY VOTER DOS
YOU THINK ARE LYING AWAKE RIGHT
NOW WORRYING THAT PUBLIC
OFFICIALS MIGHT VIOLATE OBSCURE
LAWS?
NONE.
NOT A SINGLE PERSON.
NO ONE OUTSIDE WASHINGTON CARES
OR EVEN UNDERSTANDS THE ISSUE
AND YET IN HIS CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS AND NOT OPEN BORDERS
THAT THE JUSTICE DEPARTMENT IS
PUNISHING JOE BIDEN FOR.
WASHINGTON IS PROTECTING ITSELF
AND JOE BIDEN ALONE IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THE CRIME AND HE
ALONE TOOK HOME CLASSIFIED
DOCUMENTS AND DIDN'T HAVE HELP
IN DOING THAT BUT ALLOWING THE
COUNTRY TO BE INVADED, THAT'S
NOT SOMETHING YOU CAN DO BY
YOURSELF.
SO IF BIDEN WERE SHORT TERM
ORIENTATION BE TAKEN DOWN FOR
OPENING THE SOUTHERN BORDER, A
LOT OF OTHER PEOPLE WOULD GO
WITH HIM, HE HAD A LOT OF
ACCOMPLICES.
PERMANENT WASHINGTON DOESN'T
WANT THAT AND PERMANENT
WASHINGTON IS IN CHARGE.
IT'S NOT THE DEMOCRACY YOU'D
IMAGINE WE'RE SEEING NOW.
IF YOU WANT TO UNDERSTAND AND
REALLY UNDERSTAND HOW THE
AMERICAN GOVERNMENT ACTUALLY
WORKS AT THE HIGHEST LEVELS AND
IF YOU WANT TO KNOW WHY THEY
DON'T TEACH HISTORY ANYMORE, ONE
THING YOU SHOULD KNOW IS THE
MOST POPULAR PRESIDENT IN
AMERICAN HISTORY WAS RICHARD
NIXON.
REIGNS LEADING SHADER NIXON AND
WITHOUT A SINGLE VOTE BEING CAST
BY A SINGLE AMERICAN VOTER,
RICHARD NIXON KICKED OUT OF
OFFICE AND REPLACED BY THE LEAST
POPULAR PRESIDENT IN AMERICA.
WE WENT FROM THE MOST POPULAR
PRESIDENT TO A PRESIDENT THAT
NOBODY VOTED FOR.
WHY DIDN'T I KNOW THAT?
WASN'T RICHARD NIXON A CRIMINAL
AND DESPICED BY ALL THE --
DESPISED BY ALL DECENT PEOPLE?
NO, HE WASN'T.
IF ANYONE COULD CLAIM TO BE THE
PEOPLE'S CHOICE, IT WAS NIXON.
HE WAS REELECTED IN 1972 BYES
LARGEST MARGINAL VOTE EVER
REGARDED BEFORE OR SINCE AND
NIXON GOT 17 MILLION MORE VOTES
THAN HIS OPPONENT AND LESS THAN
TWO YEARS LATER, HE WAS GONE AND
FORCED TO RESIGN AND IN HIS
PLACE AN OBEDIENT SERVANT TOOK
OVER THE WHITE HOUSE AND HOW IS
THAT HAPPENING I'LL TELL YOU
WHY.
ELEMENTS IN THE FEDERAL
BUREAUCRACY AND HE SAID THAT .
HE WAS ABSOLUTELY RIGHT AND ON
JUNE 23, 1972 AND NIXON MET WITH
CIA DIRECTOR AND RICHARD HELMS
AT THE WHITE HOUSE AND DURING
THE WHITE HOUSE HE SUGGESTED WHO
SHOT JOHN, PRESIDENT JOHN F
KENNEDY.
THE CIA WAS DIRECTLY INVOLVED IN
KENNEDY'S ASSASSINATION AND
THERE WAS.
HELMS TELLING HIS RESPONSE AND
TOTAL SILENCE.
FOR NIXON IT DIDN'T MATTER AND
IT WAS OVER.
FOUR DAYS ON JUNE 19TH, THE
WASHINGTON POST PUBLISHED A
STORY AT THE WATER GATE AND
UNREPORTED BY THE WASHINGTON
POST, FOUR OF THE FIVE BURGLARS
WORK FOR THE CIA.
FIRST OF MANY DISHONEST WATER
GATE STORIES WRITTEN BY A
29-YEAR-OLD METRO REPORTER
CALLED BOB WOOD WARD.
WHO WAS BOB WOOD WORD AND HE
WASN'T A JOURNALIST AND HE WAS
IN THE NEWS BUSINESS.
HE CAME DIRECTLY FROM THE
CLASSIFIED FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
SHORTLY BEFORE WATERGATE, THE
NAVAL OFFICE AND HE WORKED
REGULARLY WITH THE INTEL
AGENCIES AND TIMES WOOD WARD WAS
DETAILED TO THE NIXON WHITE
HOUSE WHERE HE INTERACTED WITH
RICHARD NIXON'S TOP AIDS AND
SOON AFTER LEAVING THE NAVY FOR
REASONS NEVER CLEAR WOODWARD WAS
HIRED BY THE MOST POSSIBLE LARRA
NEWS AGENCY AND GIVEN THE
BIGGEST NEWS STORY IN THE
COUNTRY.
WOODWARD'S MAIN SOURCE FOR THE
WATERGATE SERIES WASES DEPUTY
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI MARK FELT
AND MARK FELT RAN, WE'RE NOT
MAKING IT UP, THE FBI CO-INTEL
PRO PROGRAM AND WAS DESIGN
TODDIES CREDIT POLITICAL ACTORS
THE FEDERAL AGENCIES WANTED TO
DESTROY.
PEOPLE LIKE RICHARD NIXON.
AT THE SAME TIME THOSE SAME
AGENCIES WERE ALSO WORKING TO
TAKE DOWN NIXON'S ELECTED VICE
PRESIDENT.
IN THE FALL OF 1973, HE WAS
INDICTED AND FORCED TO RESIGN
AND HIS REPLACEMENT WAS A
COLORLESS CONGRESSMAN CALLED
GERALD FORD AND HE SERVED ON THE
LINE AND HE WAS ABSOLVED NOT FOR
MURDER AND HE WAS STRONG ARMED
INTO ACCEPTING GERALD FORD INTO
CONGRESS AND WE GAVE NIXON NO
CHOICE BY FORD.
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE LATER
BOASTED AND EIGHT MONTHS LATER
GERALD FORD OF THE WARREN
COMMISSION WAS THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
SEE HOW THAT WORKS?
THOSE ARE THE FACTS, NOT
SPECULATION ALL OF THAT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED AND NONE OF IT IS
SECRET AND IT'S ON WIKIPEDIA AND
IT'S SO OFFICE YET IT'S
INTENTIONALLY IGNORED.
AS A RESULT PERMANENT WASHINGTON
REMAINS IN CHARGE OF THE
POLITICAL SYSTEM.
EN ELECTED LIVES IN THE FEDERAL
AGENCY MAKE THE BIGGEST
DECISIONS IN AMERICAN GOVERNMENT
AND CRUSH ANYONE WHO TRIES TO
REIGN THEM IN AND IN THE
PROCESS, OUR DEMOCRACY BECOMES A
JOKE.
NOW NOTICE THE VERY FIRST PERSON
IN THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION
AFTER WAS GENERAL MICHAEL FLYNN?
WHY FLYNN?
HE WAS A CAREER ARMY INTEL
OFFICER THAT RAN THE DEFENSE
AGENCY AND IN OTHER WORDS HE WAS
CAPABLE OF FIGHTING BACK.
FOUR DATES AFTER HE LURED MIKE
FLYNN WITHOUT HIS LAWYER AND
CONCOCTED A SERIES OF FAKE
CRIMES AND FORCED HIM TO RESIGN.
THAT'S HOW THINGS WORK IN
WASHINGTON.
JOE BIDEN MEANWHILE LOOKED LIKE
A HYENA AND WE HAVE TO SAY
WATCHING VERY SIMILAR HAPPEN TO
JOE BIDEN HIMSELF SIX YEARS
LATER.
JOE BIDEN DOES NOT DESERVE OUR
SYMPATHY.
HE'S BEING SHAFTED AND DON'T
WEEP FOR HIM AND THE REST OF US
DO DESERVE A BETTER SYSTEM, AN
ACTUAL DEMOCRA